so my name is taka Kalakaua I'm a senior  lecturer in Japanese as the leader of  the Japanese language program I'm  shaping the direction of future  direction of the Japanese language  program and at the same time improving  the existing language calculon so the  high-level overview of the Japanese  language program at MIT is so we have  three tiers beginning intermediate and  advanced courses and each layer aims to  develop four language skills reading  speak writing speaking and listening and  our main focus however is to improve  so-called communicative skills ie be  able to communicate with native speakers  my first encounter with language  teaching was when I was a graduate  student I applied for teaching  assistantship for Japanese teaching I  originally was trained as a theoretical  linguist  so I didn't know anything about language  teaching but when I first taught  Japanese I found a great gem in language  teaching and since then I'm very  passionate about language teaching